i want to ask you this just real quick
because you're the clip we just played
on the pod of your podcast and all that
bill belichick i mean i think the same
way of some of the things you said but
tell us the the difference of when you
were playing for him and then when you
got done playing for him did was there a
difference in the way he treated you or
talked to you uh or or has it always
been the same
you know for me chris has always been
the same because it's not like once i
turn into the media that i was searching
for information so when i would call
coach belichick it wouldn't be trying to
hit him up for information or try to
steal any secrets and plus i had to be
very conscious of that because anytime i
come around i get paranoid thinking that
they think that i want some secret
information but for the most part our
relationship is great it's always been
good he's always been honest anything
that i need
you know i have an open door policy and
i just have a lot of respect for the man
well all right the uh go ahead go ahead
go ahead chris all right i was gonna say
it too all right so we're talking
belichick well so what how how do you
think bill's handling this right now
this off season everything i mean what's
going through his brain how do you think
he's going to handle this whole coven 19
training camp
well i think i mean he's going to try to
follow as as best as he can all the cdc
guidelines and everything implemented by
the nfl and nfl pa but at the end of the
day he's just like everybody else
there's a sense of uncertainty um he's
trying to figure it out on the way on
the go and um you know the thing about
coach belichick is the way he's gonna
build this team this year i think it's
gonna go back to you know once again
being fundamentally sound playing good
defense you know playing really well on
special teams and you start talking
about cam newton cam newton was that
missing piece they needed he comes in
automatically he gives him a spark he
gives us some energy and he gives him
hope you don't have hope with jared
stenham because you don't know what he's
capable of doing but at least with cam
newton you know exactly what he's done
in the past if he's healthy you know he
has a healthy nucleus around him a great
defense and a great coaching staff i
think he's going to have success chris
you mentioned cam newton we're going to
talk about him more coming up but i want
to focus on this notion of uncertainty
and everybody is dealing with the
uncertainty rodney but a lot of the
coaches out there the uncertainty is
driving them crazy they want to know
what the rules are they want to know
right now so they can plan for it i feel
like bill belichick is uniquely situated
yeah to come up with rules whatever it
is you tell me the rules now and we're
going to play a game in an hour and i'll
be ready and and i feel like that kind
of quiet confidence that bill belichick
has is going to give him an advantage
because everybody else is losing their
minds over the uncertainty and
whatever it is he's going to be fine and
he's going to have a plan and the
patriots are going to implement that
plan but also think about it too mike i
mean you look at
bill
majority of his guys on defense they're
returning i mean they have a lot of
veteran players that are returning and
you trust a lot of those veteran players
to help the young guys get acclimated
and get caught up to the system and what
they're trying to teach so a lot of
times it's devin mccourty it's a lot of
times it's jason mccourty it's patrick
chung teaching and communicating with a
lot of young players getting them up to
speed so it's not just bill belichick
and his coaching staff having to do
everything they have a good group of
guys around him that acts basically as
coaches on the field yeah i mean to me
mike and you know i don't know rodney of
course you can disagree agree whatever
but you know when i think of belichick
and the circumstances right now you know
i go advantage new england i go
advantage new england because bill is
the greatest thinker in the history of
football he is and he is you know i
would expect bill belichick right now to
probably be in the new england facility
starting to understand how guys are
going to be separated the rules whatever
else he's toying around with those
things and listen i didn't i wasn't
there as long as rodney was but two
things always jumped out to me attention
to decent detail
and efficiency i mean those are the two
things that he is going to find a way to
think about these new rules and
protocols and i would think he's going
to brainstorm and because he's so
brilliant and like we always say i think
if he worked on wall street he'd be the
wolf of wall street he's just a
brilliant man that he'll find the proper
you know techniques and system that's
going to work for his team and
everything like that what mike chris
chris the wolf of wall street went to
jail well i i i but he was the one
he was the wolf and kicking butt at one
point i just want to make sure that we
know that but yes you're right he did go
to jail hey guys but also think about
this you know any time since i've been
there anytime uh injuries occurred
anytime someone left to go to a
different team coach belichick never
makes a big deal out of anything you
know he never overreacts you see all
these other coaches they're concerned
they go to the media coach belichick
takes everything in stride so he never
panics he never gets overly
excited about anything so his players
throughout the locker room they feel the
same way they just adjust they adapt to
all different types of situation mike
and rodney it's the same attitude that
the team has always had when it comes to
injuries no excuses right because what
happens is you get players saying oh
well this year's this year is too crazy
we're worried about too many things we
got to worry about the virus this just
isn't our year no no excuses whatever
the circumstances are we're going to go
do our jobs do your job whether it's the
second string center who has to bump up
whether it's the second string
quarterback who has to take over
whatever it is we're not going to hang
our heads we're not going to say woe is
us we're just going to do what we have
to do and that's why i think that
mindset's going to serve them well this
year
yeah and he talked about brady one time
and after that i promise you he told his
teammates hey you make a statement on
brady after that we focus on the guys
that are here in the locker room that
are working that's on our team and and
that's the beautiful part about it
because he doesn't harp on guys oh if we
had this guy or if this guy didn't leave
in free agency heck if you left you're
gone he'll mention you and say thank you
and after that you never hear another
word from about that guy right
i've been trying to say that too i mean
belichick's not going to be like worried
about you know looking at the buccaneers
results every week and trying to compete
with that he's going to be staying
focused on the patriots and you know
rodney this is where i want to pick your
brain you know can we go down the cam
newton i want to go down that
conversation right now because you know
i look at it too i'm excited about it i
am i mean you made a great point you're
right he's a proven commodity there's
something to be excited about you know
you got jared stidham you know in your
pocket for the next three years anyway
so now why not take the chance on cam
newton but you know i look at it as like
80
boom 20 bust the one area i get scared
of is just the new england way can can
cam handle that you know like we talked
about the attention to detail you know
the selflessness that goes on every day
and being humble and nobody's gonna be
praising them like they probably usually
do they're gonna be like oh you hit the
pass great you're supposed to hit the
pass you know i i that's where i worry
about is there anything that you see
that could be a bump in the road or
where you think it doesn't work out
between cam and the pats
i don't chris because you got to think
about it cam newton is fighting for his
football career forget about everything
he's done in the past if he can't beat
out jared stenham first of all
he's going to be a career backup his
career like we knew it is over cam
newton is more focused more humble more
motivated than he's ever been he's more
ticked off this is the same mike you and
i talked about this same situation that
i've been i was in
when you come into a new team and you
have an opportunity to play for bill
belichick you have so much respect for
who he is what he's accomplished what
he's done
you just want to be part of something
great cam newton has made over 100
million dollars he's been to the super
bowl he's had all pros and pro bowls and
all those different things he's been the
mvp of the league now you want to come
in you want to acclimate yourself to the
system and you just want to fit in and i
think cam's going to do a great job i
think he has a lot of respect for coach
belichick josh mcdaniels i think he
respects the entire patriots
organization and cam's gonna he's gonna
play well man and think about this
you know maybe he he makes an adjustment
with his sliding or something like that
but cam newton when he plays he's going
to play the way we've always seen camden
he's going to be big aggressive and
physical hey i know we're talking about
the pats but stop banging the damn table
okay you're you're you're jugg yeah i
could hear it all right yeah yeah damn
safety
i know hey
here's here here's the wild card though
in my estimation because it's not bill
belichick and cam newton it's josh
mcdaniels and cam newton and i had
someone point out to me recently that
you know whether to what extent they can
get the right working relationship is
going to be critical we've seen times in
the past where tom brady lets josh
mcdaniels have it on the sidelines
during a game but it's the stuff that we
don't see how closely will they work
together will it mesh will it work will
josh mcdaniels dial up game plans that
get the most out of cam newton how do
you feel about mcdaniels
and newton working together the way they
need to to get the most out of his
skills
we talk about the best offensive game of
best offensive coordinators in the
national football league and in order to
be that you have to adjust your system
and it's not always you're not going to
have a guy like brady who was in his
system for two decades you got a guy
like cam newton that you have to adjust
some different things too um i heard you
guys talking about tim tebow and the way
it was 2011 or whatever he directed his
playbook he'll make some adjustments
with cam newton but think about it this
is this is a level of talent they've
never had before somebody as big as cam
yeah he's not the most accurate but he
plays with heart he plays with energy he
plays with toughness and that's enough
to spark his teammates and if he can get
nikhil harry get a few other guys
stepping up making contributions man i
think the patriots are really right now
underdog in that division yeah i i i
hear you and you know mike i could speak
to josh mcdaniels having played for him
in denver and in 2009 you know having
worked for him in in new england he he's
he's got a great way about him you know
and he is in the fight with the
quarterback it's not a guy that like
let's like oh you're the quarterback out
there and the play doesn't work i blame
you it's never my fault no he's very
real about what's going on and he has
got one of the like to rodney's point
one of the most extensive playbooks in
football it's got all the cam newton
plays in there they just got to move it
up a little bit in the playbook to where
it was pushed in the back before like we
talked about yesterday but that's to me
the key what rodney's hitting on
this is where new england's amazing with
all the moving parts over the years they
are going to go through training camp
and see the things that cam newton does
really well and they're going to build
almost another playbook off of that and
the things he doesn't do so well hey
they'll continue to work on them but
they certainly won't be as big a part of
the offense and you know i don't know
there's a lot of meme rodney that feels
like the way the patriots are built
right now it actually fits
cam newton's style of football more than
it did a tom brady where you know you
think you want to spread it out dink and
dunk i think they're built to play a cam
newton ball better actually but actually
chris i mean that's an excellent point
by you because they can still dink and
dunk you know bring up bring up cam's um
completion percentage to 65 70 percent
dinking and dunking but also running a
football everybody knows that the
patriots like to throw the ball but
their number one thing and coach
belichick talks about it all the time is
having success running the ball
obviously playing well on defense making
sure the special teams making sure that
they don't turn the ball over making
sure that they limit their uh their
penalties so it's a lot of the
fundamental stuff and the other thing
you talked about josh mcdaniels what i
personally love about him he's not one
of those guys that goes around and he
kisses butt you know it's like he has
something he's going to do a really good
job of communicating um with you um he's
not going to you know sit here and say
oh brady it's whatever you want to do
he's going to get in brady's face and
he's going to tell brady exactly how he
feels just like he'll do the same thing
to coach belichick that's why the
players take to josh mcdaniels because
he doesn't go around kissing butt
we need to take a break but let me just
underscore a point rodney made earlier
and rodney i think this is an excellent
observation if cam newton can't beat out
jared stidham
he is a career backup moving forward and
even though there isn't going to be a
pre-season even though the traditional
opportunities for a quarterback
competition aren't going to be there one
of the reasons chris and i believed that
cam newton was available for so long is
the other teams were afraid to bring a
cam newton in because he instantly is
better than your starter and from the
first practice that the players are
gonna go to the locker room they're
gonna say
holy crap why is he the backup and in
new england
it's not like jared stidham is going to
go pout in the corner and if he does
bill belichick and say stay in the
corner we'll find somebody else to be
the backup right
absolutely do we have to go to a break
or do i have time
no you can say something go ahead
no i mean you're absolutely right and
then as a player think about it if i'm
devin mccourty and i just lose tom brady
and all of a sudden in the off season
i'm like what the heck is this jared
stenham gonna do will we as a defense do
we really have to be the number one
defense in the league to win now then
all of a sudden cam newton signs you're
like holy crap man we got a legitimate
chance like we can win this division you
automatically forget about tom brady and
you feel like you give yourself a really
legitimate chance of winning that
division and getting back into the
playoffs and having success
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports